the seafront at penn arthur wasn't what
ella had planned for her summer holiday
and while hope is rising for quarantine
free travel for the double dosed
at 18 that feels a long way off i'm glad
that kind of
the older generation get to go on
holiday since they're the people who
we've been protecting this year
with kind of staying inside and i think
it's nice that they get to be able to do
that but it would have been nice to kind
of be able to do that thing of like
going on a trip to celebrate the end of
school but i'm not too disappointed
about it because i wasn't really holding
out any hope that after kovid would be
able to do that but it would have been a
nice celebration
the 26th of july is reportedly the day
that fully vaccinated people could be
exempt from
amber's own quarantine the prime
minister says there'll be announcement
within days
i'm very confident that the the double
jabs
uh will be a a liberator
and they will enable uh people to
uh to travel we'll be sending out a lot
more about the detail of that in in the
course of
of july in the in the course the next
few days
about how we see it working but there's
no doubt at all that once you've got two
jabs
uh you are in a in a much better vision
it's much more complicated
boris johnson's meeting the german
chancellor tomorrow to discuss relaxing
the rules for british travelers
at the moment it's a messy picture in
germany
all british travelers have to quarantine
for 14 days
but in spain travelers with a negative
test don't need to isolate on arrival
in recently green listed malta
passengers have been asked to show
not just proof on the nhs app but a
medical letter
that says they've had two vaccines all
this confusion like
you need an app you don't need the app
you need a bit of paper i mean
needing a bit of paper when we're in the
technological age just seems a bit
strange and sort of the maltese were
saying it's the government's fault for
not giving them the authority to access
the software
and i don't know i mean it just was all
very confusing
consistency matters and as europe
launches its digital covid pass
a deal for mutual recognition with our
nhs pass
is being worked on the code that could
unlock
shores beyond britain ali fuldski sky
news